- Beautifully wrapping a
present is a way of making
your last minute, bullshit
gift seem fantastic.
- I grew up with my
dad owning a toy store.
- Just a fat guy under the coat.
- Didn't like it, boo hoo.
- Let's do this.
- Usually, if you're
a good enough wrapper,
you don't actually have to cut,
you can just kind of slide.
- You get the half crack right here.
- Edges right.
- These are serrated scissors,
so it's a little bit tougher.
- Boom!
- Beautifully wrapped present.
- You're getting your kid a ball, like,
why are you wrapping it?
- This one's a little tougher.
- This is so hard.
- It's gettin' there, it's gettin' there.
- With a ball, every side is up.
- Back in the glory days, I wrapped
a four foot giraffe with my dad.
- You know what, this is the best
it's gonna get on this side.
- Spike that.
- Most people get freaked out by these,
but they're actually not that bad.
- Doesn't need wrapping.
- It's like an operating table.
- We're gonna tuck your
head between your legs.
- Kinda gotta get a little
kinky with the bear.
- My mom taught me how
to just like slide the--
Oh, shh...
- It's a little Christmas burrito.
- You might as well just
put this in a garbage bag
and be like hey, got you some crap.
- What kid wants a globe?
- Doesn't this come in a box?
- There's no South Sudan.
- Oh, shit.
- We're gonna make a little globe burrito.
- I'd rather get coal than a globe.
- You know what?
- As I'm doing this, I'm
beginning to really feel like
gift cards are, like, a great idea.